i feel is that i put across my case
that the conservatives need a bold new
economic plan we need to get growth
going people are struggling with the
cost of living and that's why we need to
cut taxes and it's why we need to take
the bold post-brexit reforms
do the different regulations so that we
can get more investment right across our
country including into places like
stoke-on-trent that's what people want
to see they want to see bold action i'm
the prime minister that can deliver that
did you get annoyed with rishi sunak
interrupting you
i put my case across i think the
audience understood what i was saying
and that i am on the side of people who
work hard who do the right thing and
that is the kind of government i would
run the fact is that the current
business as usual policy isn't working
it's not delivering the cr for people
across britain i'm an optimist about the
future i think we're a country with
great potential and i want us to do more
i want us to be better and i can lead
that change yeah and i do want to ask
you about those plans but
about the nature of the contest how have
you found it because a lot of people
have been commenting at tim montgomery
for one saying it was an unedifying
experience that richie saint was
interrupting you you've got nadine doris
attacking rishi sunak on twitter how do
you feel about the way some of your
supporters have been behaving
well i feel that this is a contest that
is incredibly important it's about the
future direction of britain it's about
do we want to be bold do we want to lead
in the world do we want to attract the
investment into towns and cities across
the country that's the positive case i'm
putting across yeah but and do you
appreciate nadine dory's support
look i have a fantastic range of
supporters from all parts of the
conservative party and what is true
about all of them is they've worked with
me in government they know i'm somebody
who does what i say i'll do i don't make
my promises and i get things done and
that is what britain needs was rishi
soon at mansplaining
look i'm not going to criticize the
other candidate in this race i'm putting
forward a positive case about what we
need to change in britain to unleash the
potential of people across this country
i want to support those who go out to
work they're self-employed those who run
small businesses those who get things
done to drive our country forward those
are the people i back big strike on the
railways tomorrow if you were prime
minister what would you do about it i
would legislate to make sure that there
are essential services on our railway is
completely wrong
that the traveling public are being held
ransom by militant unions we can't allow
that to happen we need to make sure our
essential services run as i've said i'm
on the side of people who work hard who
go into work who want to run their
businesses we can't see them hampered by
the activities of these militant unions
the people who work hard as well they
work on the railways and for the train
companies
well those people are well rewarded for
the work they do
and what is wrong is to try and hold the
travelling public to ransom
i will take a tough line
on trade union action that is not
helping people get on in life mick lynch
the boss at the rmt has said that your
attack on trade union and civil rights
is the biggest since labor unions were
legalized in 1871 he says that you are
robbing working people of a key
democratic right and that if these
proposals become law there will be the
biggest resistance mounted by the entire
trade union movement
rivaling the general strike of 1926.
well i don't take any notice of these
bellicose threats i'm on the side of the
traveling public who need to get into
work to do their jobs we're facing a
global economic crisis
is completely irresponsible of the trade
unions to call these strikes at the time
as we're seeking to get the economy
going and i will legislate to make sure
that those core services are provided to
the public and speaking about the
economic crisis the imf have just
released a world economic
update and they've said and i'll just
read you this paragraph it says targeted
fiscal support can help cushion the
impact on the most vulnerable but with
government budgets stretched by the
pandemic and the need for an overall
disinflationary macroeconomic policy
stance offsetting targeted support with
higher taxes or lower government
spending will ensure that fiscal policy
does not make the job of monetary policy
even harder in other words they're
saying rishi sunak's plan to not to cut
taxes and to keep spending down is the
way forward let's be clear his plan is
to raise taxes
he is planning to raise taxes on
corporations putting our taxes up to the
same level as france that is going to
put off people who want to invest in
britain and i know there are masses of
opportunities right across the country
less investment will mean fewer jobs
fewer opportunities and lower wages and
lower productivity in the future so it's
cutting off our nose to spite our face
the fact is that we promised in our
manifesto not to raise national
insurance i thought it was wrong at the
time to do so
and that is why i'd reverse that i also
want to put money into people's pockets
i could quote you the oecd who said that
our current policy is contractionary and
what that means is it will lead to a
recession a recession would be a
disaster it would be a disaster for
people who are homeowners it would be a
disaster for people who go out to work
it would be a disaster for people to run
who run businesses that is why i want to
keep taxes low attract the investment
get the growth that's the best way to
pay down our debt but you agree that
your strategy backed by a minority of
economists that that's what you're
asking conservative members to vote for
compared to a majority of
economists i don't base my policies on
you know the number of economists
the question is who is right
the fact is we are one of the few g7
countries that are putting up taxes
countries like the united states canada
japan have higher levels of debt than us
they're not putting up taxes because
they understand that now is the time we
need to get the economic growth into our
economy to avoid a recession and to make
sure that we are attracting business
investment and those jobs and greater
future i'm sick of this decline this
talk this idea that britain can't
succeed that we can't compete we
absolutely can but we need to be open
for business at this vital time